les argentins doivent élire leur
président mais ce n'est pas de gaieté de
coeur
mauricio macri 60 ans et au pouvoir
depuis quatre ans et bien sûr il veut y
rester
ce ne sera pas facile son adversaire
s'appelle alberto fernandez il a été
ministre dans un gouvernement de nestor
kirchner du parti péroniste décédé en
2007 et à qui son épouse cristina
fernandez a succédé alberto fernandez se
présente à la présidence mais la vedette
cl cristina fernandez de kirchner
elle serait sa vice-présidente lequel
des deux fernandez aura vraiment le
pouvoir
c'est une question que les électeurs se
posent les deux fernandez d'autant qu'un
lien de parenté mais ils sont du même
parti même si on les dit pas très bons
amis mais ce qui va aider c'est que
cristina fernandez kirchner est encore
très aimé dans les classes populaires
elle n'hésite pas à s'identifier à la
légendaire évita peron qu'elle soit
l'objet d'une douzaine de poursuites
pour corruption au cours des douze ans
qu'elle et son mari ont gouverné
qu'importe ils voteront pour elle nous
sommes dans le quartier via 21 au bureau
de vote de l'école secondaire république
d'haïti le quartier pauvre défavorisés
et bien sûr la crise économique touche
et habitant encore plus qu'ailleurs
c'est évident que les gens ici vont
voter pour les fernandez surtout pour
christina parce qu'elles aident les
pauvres situation difficile qui
l'obligent à vendre de la nourriture
dans la rue
[Musique]
magri c'est lui qui a mis le pays dans
la pas question de voter pour lui dit
elle dans les quartiers plus aisés les
opinions sont partagées on s'inquiète
d'un retour du péronisme populisme de
gauche avec son protectionnisme qui
décourage les investisseurs et les
subventions qui provoquent des
distorsions dans l'économie mais il ya
une constante
à mon avis le greffe et matrix et
accélérer l'église à la création ding
cévennes avait développé des années
marissiaux macri n'était pas à la
hauteur
et pour ce politicien de centre-droit ce
qui se passe au chili son modèle
économique n'est pas de bon augure
on croit toujours que l'argentine va mal
mais ça ne peut pas être pire et bien
celle là
l'argentine c'est un grand baie il y
avait beaucoup de problèmes structurels
que personne pour ger et de la
corruption et la collusion c'est le
cancer causé des cancers de la gêne des
décisions difficiles pour les argentins
c'est un peu comme leur demander de
choisir entre la peste et le choléra
maintenant toute la question est de
savoir si cette décision sera prise au
premier tour ça prend 45 % des voix ou
40% et un écart de dix points
sinon il y aura un deuxième tour fin
novembre jean michel leprince
radio-canada à buenos aires